[موسيقى]
نحن الذاكرة الوحيدة في جميع
جبال الهيمالايا في المهراجا القاتلة ،
يمكن لهؤلاء الراهبات كسر الطوب
بأيديهم والغرض من هذه
الممارسة مقدس ،
فهو مثل الصندوق الطويل
وجعله لأبوين وأنا فخور جدًا
ممارستي ، اسمي جينغ مي يوين جينغ
فاصلة سيجما تعني أنني لست خائفًا أنا
عنصر في ترتيب Troopa ، فإن ترتيب دروبا
هو فرع من البوذية
كان موجودًا منذ آلاف السنين ولكن
في عام 2008 بدأت دير الراهبات في كاتماندو
نيبال في  تعلم الكونغ فو كجزء
من ممارستهم الروحية 800 راهبة أنا
هنا آكل المراسل نام جيج مي أرادت أن
تكون راهبة منذ أن كانت طفلة صغيرة كان عمري
10 سنوات عندما أصبحت ثم يمكنني
أن أقول كل الراهبات مثل عائلتي  لا توجد
أي دير للراهبات في نيبال من خلال
التدريب ، و Jigme وأخواتها يبذلون
جهدًا إضافيًا لإتقان هذا الفن من
الشكل ، فالقوة الحقيقية ليست للأشخاص الكسالى الذين
نستيقظ في الساعة 3 صباحًا ، نحن نتأمل ،
نحن نتدرب بالدراجة لمدة ثلاث ساعات يركضون فيها
و  يصعد السلالم إلى شارع  يحركون
أجسادهم ويستخدمون العصي والمعجبين
لتعزيز تنسيقهم ، والعمل الجاد
مجزي والغرض من تدريب
هؤلاء الراهبات على القتال يعود
إلى فلسفات السلام والمساواة
بدلاً من تدريبنا على التركيز على الخطوط العريضة
للتأمل ، وتأخذ الراهبات هذه أيضًا.
الفلسفات وتطبيقها على
المجتمعات المحرومة في نيبال
في عام 2015 عندما ضرب زلزال مدمر
كاتماندو ، علمت الراهبات أن هذه كانت
دعوتهن للعمل أثناء
الزلزال ، استجابت لدعوتنا لأي مساعدة لنا
على الشجاعة والقوة ، ذهبنا إلى العديد من
القرى التي العديد من المنظمات غير الحكومية والحكومة
اعتقدنا أنه أمر خطير للغاية ،
اشترينا العديد من الإمدادات ، لقد نجونا من
الانهيارات الأرضية والانهيارات الجليدية وخرجنا سريعًا
من الراهبات أيضًا بالدراجات لمسافة 14000 ميل في
جميع أنحاء نيبال للاحتجاج على
الاتجار بالبشر للنساء والفتيات ،
نتحدث كثيرًا عن المساواة في الأمان ،
أردنا أن نظهر للجميع أن المروج
تستطيع  ركوب الدراجة وتستطيع الفتيات فعل
أي شيء تعلمته أنني أستطيع فعل أي شيء
دربني الزورق على أن أكون
ج  ساعدتني التعاليم القوية والواضحة في
وضع تعاطفي موضع التنفيذ ،
ومساعدة الآخرين هي ديني
[موسيقى]
أوه